CONSIDERATIONS INTO ACCOUNT AS
HE MOVES FORWARD WITH THIS.
>> Dana: THIS IS ALSO
HAPPENING IN AN ELECTION YEAR,
THE PRESIDENT IS RUNNING FOR
REELECTION AND THEN YOU HAVE
FORMER VICE PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN
WHO IS SORT OF JUST HANGING IN
THE WINGS THEY ARE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO MAKE HIS MARK,
I DON’T KNOW IF HIS CAMPAIGN OR
THAT CANDIDATE ARE PARTICULARLY
WELL-SUITED FOR THIS MOMENT
WHERE YOU’RE ISOLATED IN YOUR
HOUSE AND YOU’RE TRYING TO DO
COMMUNICATION THROUGH -- IN YOUR
LIVING ROOM, DOESN’T FEEL LIKE
IT’S GOING TO WORK WELL.
>> YEAH, WELL IT HASN’T THUS
FAR, HE PUT HIS STUDIO IN HIS
REC ROOM, MADE A SPEECH, THE
FIRST ON THE TELEPROMPTER GAVE
OUT ON HIM, HE’S NOT VERY
REASSURING WHEN HE SAYS THINGS
LIKE "COME ON, MAN," HE’S GOT AN
ADVERSARIAL RELATIONSHIP WITH
THE TELEPROMPTER.
HE’S TRYING TO PLAY IN AN ARENA
THAT I DON’T THINK HE OUGHT TO
BE PLAYING IN, HE’S TRYING TO
SORT OF SAY, AND THE CRITIC OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND LET’S REEL
BACK TO 2008, BARACK OBAMA WAS
THE PRESUMPTIVE NOMINEE IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, ADMITTEDLY IT
WAS THE FALL AND AFTER THE
CONVENTION, BUT BIDEN IS THE
PRESUMPTIVE NOMINEE, OBAMA WAS
THE NOMINEE BUT OBAMA WENT IN
AND WAS OF THE LEADER OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, SITTING THERE
WITH NANCY PELOSI AND HARRY REID
SAYING IS ORGANA DO IN RESPONSE
TO THE FINANCIAL CRISIS AND IN
THIS INSTANCE JOE BIDEN HAS
NEVER BEEN THE LEADER OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY BUT HE IS THE
LEADER NOW AND INSTEAD OF ACTING
LIKE THE LEADER HE SORT OF LET
NANCY PELOSI BE THE PRIMARY
FIGURE IN THE NEGOTIATIONS ON
WHAT WAS GOING TO GO INTO THE
BILL AND CHUCK SCHUMER TO BE HER
SIDE MAN AND HE WAS JUST
BASICALLY BUYING INTO EVERYTHING
THEY DID.
WHEN SHE THROUGHOUT THAT 1800
PAGE BILL WITH $35 MILLION FOR
THE KENNEDY CENTER, $100 MILLION
FOR PUBLIC RADIO, THE SAME DAY
REGISTRATION AND YOU KNOW,
BALLOT HARVESTING NOW MADE
ILLEGAL, HE WAS IN ESSENCE
BUYING AND ALL THAT STUFF AND
YET --
>> Dana: INSTEAD OF STANDING
UP AND SAYING STOP.
HE HAD SAID WERE NOT DOING THIS,
NO MORE KENNEDY CENTER MONEY IN